hier ligne droite
non parisiens
tour au pays
un défilé de haute couture un spectacle
qui est surtout la vitrine de sa
créativité et de son travail cette année
son thème et sa scénographie se décline
sous le signe du chic et sauvage une
gamme de couleurs chatoyantes des motifs
voilà les motifs animaliers végétaux
vont là ce sont des papillons par
exemple un côté seul jeu japonisant
venir voilà des fougères on est parti
sur vraiment du coût des mélanges voyait
la toile de jouy marron dans les mares
ans et des canards mais mélangé au
fuchsia toujours dans les matières
nobles
[Musique]
mais en osant mélanger les motifs
totalement différente
son credo de couturier c'est le haut de
gamme
la pièce unique des tissus prestigieux
mais accessible à toutes les femmes
tourangelle d'aujourd'hui du 36 au 42
ses vêtements vont défiler sur le dos de
mannequin à l'image de la population
tourangelle effectivement on voit déjà
la diversité on voit des femmes urnes
afin de marier on voit des jeunes femmes
voilà il y en a des très grandes
les plus grands doivent fin dans les
remakes 79 avec mélanie et il est plus
62 5 fois plus petit qu'on a cette année
chaque année le défilé de la collection
de jean marie bataille attire près de
800 personnes à montrichard